طريقه
تفكير الاوروبيين ردات افعال الاوروبيين
عن اكلنا هو اللي خلق عندي هذا الشغف او
ساعد على انه هذا الشغف يصير اكبر واكبر
او حتى الحوارات اللي كانت تجربه بيني
وبينهم عن الطعام خلتني احس انه انا لازم
اعرف اكثر عن ثقافه طعامنا
اكثر عن تاريخ وحضاره المطبخ العربي بشكل
عام ومطبخ ليفانتي مطبخ بلاد الشام يعني
دعم اللي هو كان من زوجي ومن دائرتي
المقربه اهلي امي اخواتي
خالعتي عمومي هاي دائره دائره الصغيره
اللي كانت جدا الى اثر ايجابي لانه كانوا
عم يدعموني بغض النظر نحن في عندنا دائما
احكام مسبقه انا طالبه كنت بدرس علاقات
دوليه وعلوم دبلوماسيه وادب عربي فدائما
نحن بمجتمعنا هي الطبقه هي الطبقه
المتعلمه والمثقفه ما لازم تقرب على
المهنيه اللي احنا بنعتبر الطباخ هو شخص
مهني تماما مثل مثل الاعمال المهنيه اللي
بشتغل بالاحداده رغم انه هاي كلياتها فنون
ولكن هيك ثقافه المجتمع بشكل عام اهلي ما
تطلعوا على هذا الموضوع بهذه الطريقه
بالعكس اعتبروا انه هذا قد يكون فن وقد
يكون نافذه لحتى شيء من عن مجتمعنا بهذا
الطريقه وبهذا الاسلوب
فهذا الشيء كثير كان عم يدعمني
[موسيقى]
انه ما كنت قبل بعرف كثير عن المطبخ يعني
وصفات صغيره كنت ممكن احضر والدتي هي عم
تطبخها بالمطبخ باوقات فراغ
كتير قليله عندي بما انه كنت بدرس وبشتغل
بسوريا فما كان عندي هذا الوقت لحتى انا
اكون
صديقه والدتي بالمطبخ فهذا كان تحدي تحدي
الثاني انه كيف
المواد الاوليه طوعها لحتى اقدر اعمل
الطبق اللي انا بذاكرتي تماما بمواد هي
انا معتمد على عليها مثلا الباذنجان
الكبير الكوسا الكبيره اللي نحن ما عندنا
اياها اصلا ببلادنا اني انا من خلال
طريقه الطبخ الفت نظر الاوروبيين لانه
الموضوع مو فقط تذوق مثل ما قلت فن حتى
العيون بدها تاكل فانا بدي اعرف كيف اني
اجذبهم لعندي كيف خليهم انه هن عندهم حب
لحتى يدوقوا هذا الطبق من خلال عيونهم اول
شيء الرائحه طبعا بس اخر شيء بيجي الذوق
فهادا الشي كمان كان تحدي رقم ثلاثه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شهرين ثلاثه شهور وكنت حامل بالشهر الثاني
عملت ايفنت ل 350 شخص على مدى تسعه ايام
يعني كل تسع كل يوم عندي 350 شخص بدهم
يجوا
الطعام السوري يعني نحن عم نحكي تقريبا
3500 شخص طبخت لهم على مدى تسعه ايام هذا
الشيء كان تحدي جدا كبير انا كنت كتير
جديده طبخت لاهم مئه شخصيه المانيه في
العالم هذا الشيء كان بسنه 2019 حاليا
كمان
غير اني انا فتحت مطعم باسمي كمان اسمه
ملكه
حاليا ان جزء ببروجكت اسمه منافسته هو
بروجكت الماني
بضم اهم عشرين مطعم موجودين ببرلين في
مستثمر كندي او جاء لهذا المكان لحتى يكون
مكان تجمع الثقافات طعامه موجوده فيه وانا
كنت العربيه الوحيده اللي موجوده فيه
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
اجت فكره الكتاب من خلال
تفكيري بفلسفه طعامنا كلياته وذكريات
الطعام رائحه الطعام كلياتها هي خلقت عندي
هيك انه كيف بنطبخ هي الاكله ليش بنطبخها
بالصيف ما بنطبخها بالشتاء هي الاكله يا
ترى بتذكرنا في لكل قسم جزء بذاكرتنا من
جوا لكل اكله
فحسيت انه انا بحب انه احكي اكثر عن هذا
الموضوع بكتاب ليش منسمي هاي الاكلات في
اسماء مضحكه احيانا
لطبخاتنا فكل مره صرت
احكام عن هذا الموضوع قدام اصدقائي
الالمان يشجعوني على فكره التدوين هذا
الشيء وخاصه انه الشعب الالماني بشكل عام
بيحبوا الكتاب فحتى في مثل بالمانيا بيقول
انه
اذا انجبت طفل
وزراعه شجره والفت كتاب فانت الان في فانت
الان خالد
فقر رت بالسنه يعني انا كنت حامل فيها
اني اصنع كتاب
وازرع الشجره بالمانيا وانجب طفل لحتى
اطبق هذه الحكمه الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا الملوخيه يعني هيك من غير ما افكر
دغري الملوخيه ما حدا بيتخيل قديش متمنيه
انه اكلها من على الطنجره وكون ببيتنا
بالشام
وبس
[موسيقى]
كلمه صعبه مستحيل غير موجوده الاشياء
المستحيله بالحياه انه حدا مات وترجعوا
تعيشوا غير هيك الحياه كتير متواعبه بين
ايدينا انه نحن نقدر نشتغل عليها نكون
اقوياء لانك قلتي مراه امراه يعني كائن
قوي جدا